aumenta la lista de los fallecidos por
el paso del huracán Ian por territorio
estadounidense las autoridades dieron a
conocer que las víctimas se contabilizan
en más de 80 el número puede aumentar a
medida que las aguas se retrocedan de
las zonas inundadas la mayoría de las
muertes se concentran en el estado de
Florida donde continúan las labores de
rescate en zonas incomunicadas
las operaciones de rescate están en
curso tenemos datos excelentes sobre las
operaciones que se han llevado a cabo
Obviamente si alguien llama al 911
acudirán Y responderán a eso si alguien
ha puesto algún tipo de mensaje que
están en algún lugar y necesitan ayuda
lo harán
segundos el 93% del territorio ya cuenta
con energía eléctrica con el avance de
la inspección de las autoridades locales
salen a la luz nuevas imágenes de la
devastación los testimonios son igual de
impresionantes la dureza de los vientos
marcaron a este residente en una isla de
la costa oeste de la península
teníamos ventanas de vidrio ventanas
corredizas en el golfo que eran aptas
para soportar hasta 240 kilómetros por
hora así que me sentí bastante seguro al
estar tras ellas pero cuando el vidrio
explotó y comenzó a romperse en el
interior y cuando el segundo juego de
ventanas corredizas que era la segunda
Barrera interior cuando estallaron me di
cuenta que esto era un problema
el presidente Joe biden en la primera
dama Jill biden visitarán Puerto Rico
este lunes y la Florida el miércoles en
la primera parada cientos de miles de
personas no contaban con electricidad
dos semanas después del paso de Ian por
esa zona